The answer is that any column
corresponding to a positive entry of rD
is a good candidate.
We want the entry to be positive
because the corresponding value of xD
is also going to be
positive as we increase it.
Just picking the greatest entry, rD,
doesn't work because this
still might be negative.
This idea then becomes the basis for
the simplex algorithm.
Pick a q such that rDq is positive and
we'll let xD just
be some scalar times the unit vector
along the qth coordinate axis.
This choice simplifies the optimization
even further, since D times xD is
now just gamma times the Dth
column of the matrix D.
We'll define this B inverse
time this column as u, and
we'll define B inverse times b as v.
Of course,
the greater the gamma the more I get to
increase the objective value, so
i want to make it as big as possible.
But how big can I make it?